jose barrios the record
seven and three very good era
pop-up short center
and on just six pitches carrios has a
one two three first inning
and the twins will face willie peralta
listen in his last outing guys he was
fantastic seven
innings against the texas rangers now
the two two matty's struck him out
nice job by willie peralta
2-2 pitch a fly ball into right deep
larnett going back on the track near the
wall jumps up and larnick makes the play
up against the wall near the 365
sign from sunshine to shade leaping up
catching and crashing lordic makes a
great play
for route number three no score bottom
two
runner goes the pitch is low throw to
second base
is going to be safe now good throw from
rogers and polanco kind of angle this
size slide towards the
center field side of second base to
avoid the swipe tag of the shortstop
zach short the pitch was a strike i
thought it was low but it was a strike
and a close play polanco called safe as
he got the left hand
just pinned up against the corner
towards right field
the 3-1 lifted to left
haas is there and puts it away
two and two to castro nice
bad swing and strength three
for rios's first strikeout seven up
seven down
two strikes and air strike three took a
few extra pitches
but barrios has three no hit innings and
we've got a scoreless game
simmons waits on the three two there
goes the runner and this one is
flared into center but dude nice running
catch
he'll flip it all the way to first and
that will be
a double play for the tigers the dude
gets a good jump on this
ball here you can get full with the
swing a lot of times big swing
and you look at it but you look at
jeffers here he never looked at but
didn't think for a second that he was
going to get to this ball
and he got too far around second base
that there was no chance of him getting
back there
01 to donald's off the end of the bat
and he's upset but the tigers are
thrilled
candelario and scope almost collide
scope
grabs it for the final out that was
dangerous any time
two big guys like that get close you got
to watch those knees
right yes that was the scary part about
it
somebody both of them calling for it
scope is the one who dialed it in
there goes grossman and strike three is
called and grossman
is off the bag and he's out he over slid
second base
he got there but then overslid the bag
grossman not moving he wants the tigers
to take a look at it but second base
umpire dan murzell
emphatically said he came off the bag
and polanco
kept the tag so a two out
base hits a two out walk and rogers will
come up with two men on
yeah that's so frustrating for a pitcher
here's the three one and a walk to
rogers
to load them up a 25 pitch inning for
jose barrios
the tiger is threatening here now jake
rogers works him for a walk seven eight
nine hitters
have loaded up the bases for a keel
badoo
the o2 drives it to left and that's in
for a base hit
harold castro scores and so does zach
short it's a two-run hit for aquil badu
on an 0-2 pitch the rookie comes through
goes the opposite way
and the tigers are in the early lead
scope the other way and that's going to
drop in front of larnach
another run is home aquil badu scores as
well
and it's a four-nothing tigers lead well
you like that the tigers are being very
patient i talked about getting after
burrills making him work chip
and now that they've the second time
around guys there's
second third time around guys starting
to pick up the baseball a lot better
to left hit pretty well haas going back
to the wall
gone kepler to the opposite field again
his tenth of the year oh we've seen all
these
twins left-hand hitters kiralof as well
as
kepler and larnick power to all fields
and now max
in the last week with a couple of
opposite field home runs that he has not
had before
it will be the switching in polanco as
the tying run with two out here in the
sixth inning
poke to right field at base head crews
being waved around third
grossman's throw coming to the second
baseman and the twins take advantage of
the wildness
and score at least one more here in the
sixth by design
no intention to try to pull that ball
with a hole perfect spot
and as the guys in the dugout say keep
the line moving just keep tacking on
those singles
so he inherits three runners and he'll
pitch to kiriloff who walked his last
time up
to the backstop scampering home
one run will score and donaldson gets
back to third
a wild pitch scoring one yesterday
the twins were able to get two runs on a
wild pitch
tigers wildness continues not even
close to the target
to left field and down for a hit
crews will be held at third but the
tying run
scores and kiriloff drops a soft single
lap to tie the game so it's a 4-4
score and here comes jorge polancos
now the 2-2 pitch a line drive up the
middle base hit center field
grows scores kirill off to second
polanco does it again
five four twins in the seventh
poke to right field and down for a head
kiriloff will score and the twins keep
piling on runs against the tiger bullpen
6-4 twins lead first pitch to badoo
misses now he hits a fly ball to right
field this one's deep got some carry to
it and that ball is gone
a home run kill badou with number six
and the tigers answer right back pulled
to within one now down
six to five oh good to see that ball
just jumped off the kill but dude's bad
he did good swings in the last couple of
days
driven deep to center field
off the base of the wall simmons will
score
and donaldson to second with a scalding
double
off the center field fence
why take you i'll take you back a couple
decades i think
josh thought he had all of it he had
most of it but
remember when dick allen hit two inside
the park home runs and bobby darwin is
in center that ball went knuckling out
there
the same way
what a stop by castro but he can't make
the play
rounding third heading home the run
scores
donaldson of all people scoring from
second on an infield hit we've seen him
make a number of nice plays going to his
right he nearly made a great one going
to his left wow
jake has drawn a couple of walks scored
a run and struck out tigers are down
three now they have the potential tying
run on
first pitch to jake swinging a fly ball
to center this one's deep
way back kepler looking up and it's off
the top of the wall
and gone oh man
jake rogers grand slam
home run in the ninth stuns the twins
the tigers take a nine eight
lead one two pitch a fly ball
into right field and deep back it goes
deep it goes
tai yay unbelievable
spotted cal for everybody ben rortman
to right field a no doubter
nine nine in the ninth inning did not
have that on the bingo card
and work that's gonna hurt somebody's
hand with those high fives
what a stop it first by carol off and
he gets to the bag
what a play by carol to end the top of
the 10.
polanco now bats three two count one out
and the payoff pitch will swing to line
drive into left field and deep
back it goes ball game
twins win the game on a polanco
walk off three run homer it'll be a
happy all-star break for the twins as
they sweep the tigers in four
what a game today 12-9 the final here at
target field